kamala harris and other figures in the
democratic party encouraged the mob
torching kenosha wisconsin in the summer
of 2020 kyle rittenhouse decided to try
to defend the city a car lot
specifically was asked by the owner to
help defend the car lock because the
police weren't there he worked in
kenosha his family's father lived there
so he shows up and a child molester
tries to murder him and kyle rittenhouse
defends himself two other people try to
kill him too one with a gun
so for doing that he was put on trial
and charged with murder he was acquitted
but at the same time virtually every
news organization in the country defamed
him they called him a murderer before
the trial had ended and they called him
repeatedly a white supremacist which he
is not
tech platforms enabled that defamation
now kyle ridden house is taking legal
action against them kyle rittenhouse is
the founder of the media accountability
project todd mcmurtry is his lawyer they
join us now to explain what they're
doing thanks to you both uh for coming
on tell us kyle
good to see you
what action are you taking against the
tech companies that made this defamation
possible
well we're gonna make the media pay for
what they did to me they made it hard
for me to live a normal life i can't go
out into public
i can't go to the store it's hard for me
to go anywhere without security shoot
doing basic things like taking my dog to
the dog park is difficult so
they made it really difficult to be
normal and they affected future job
opportunities to me i don't think i'll
ever be able to work or get a job
because i'm afraid an employer may not
hire me
you know well i think that's entirely
fair because of the lies
repeated for over a year by the tech
platforms that are not journalists
they're
soldiers in some sort of weird partisan
war they're fighting so what are you
doing to rectify this
well we're going to be taking that to
court i'll go
go ahead todd
tell us the legal action yeah
okay sure to answer your first question
with regard to what we plan to do with
the tech companies of course we're
looking at those and i think the first
one that i'm taking a look at is
facebook
mark zuckerberg announced in a videotape
that what kyle was involved in was a
mass murder and that's clearly
defamatory as well
that's not protected by section 230 the
communications decency act in my opinion
section 230 allows you to take down you
know violent things or or you know
things that that people don't want to
hear but telling the truth about kyle is
not something that section 230 enabled
facebook to take down so that's an
example of what we plan to do with tech
and also plan to do in the defamation
arena
and by defamation do you mean with
so-called news organizations
absolutely i mean as you mentioned some
of that on on the way in and certainly
kyle was charged with a crime news
organizations are allowed to report on
that but you know calling somebody a
murderer in certain circumstances can be
actionable other things that uh
media personalities people on social
media said were clearly defamatory i
think your comment about calling kyle a
white supremacist is made up out of thin
air i don't know how a media can claim
that they didn't make a statement made
up out of thin air without engaging in
actual malice or most certainly
negligence so i think that we have some
strong grounds to proceed
we're looking at we're starting to look
at all those we're going to evaluate
them and look for opportunities to hold
the media and to hold tech accountable
as kyle's promised
so kyle when you go into public
do people repeat to you things that they
saw on social media or on say nbc news
or cnn
there's been a few people i've received
some harassment and
thank goodness for my security lttc and
kenny and dave for helping me like not
have to get harassed to make sure that
they like keep me safe and if somebody
does come up to me they make sure that
they're not going to harm me so thank
god for them
yeah um and todd really quick how
exactly are you going going to go after
zuckerberg
well i think we're going to we're going
to sue a for the defamatory statements
that uh kyle engaged in mass murder and
b for violations of section 230 by
taking down posts that were told the
truth about kyle so in essence they
suppressed the truth by taking down
truthful post and they did that in
violation of section 230. that
communications decency act does not
provide that protection yeah well that's
exactly right it's it's not just that
they defamed him but they also took down
any defense of him or the facts about
him as it did with the vaccines and a
million other things the war in ukraine
um i appreciate
what you all are doing thank you both
kyle great to see you thank you todd
thank you thank you tucker thank you
tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight